and judy are you interested in i have a
parrot
yes
yes yes yes because i was given a parrot
at christmas really yes this is news to
me a ch charming
charming parrot called sweetheart
and she's lived with a man
charming's lived 14 years 14 years yes
now she's come to me
i said to david who brought her to me
does she speak
and he said oh yes she'll speak all
right and she goes
what are you doing
what are you doing about half past 11 in
the morning she says bedtime
but i've tried you know being very
refined and hoping that she might do a
bit of to be or not to be i do repeat
that a lot just goes
she goes
looks at me sideways bedtime
[Applause]
[Music]
you